[MUSIC PLAYING]
METE ATAMEL: My
name is Mete Atamel.
I am a developer advocate
at Google based in London.
JAMES WARD: Hi, I'm James Ward.
I'm a developer
advocate in Colorado.
METE ATAMEL: First
of all, thanks
for being here so early in the
morning after the after party.
If you went there,
I'm impressed.
Today we're going to be talking
about multi-regional apps
on Google Cloud.
So when you think about
multi-regionality,
there's actually
two aspects to that.
The first one is running your
code in a multi-regional way.
And that's what we're
going to cover here
today in this presentation.
But the second aspect
is storing your data
in a multi-regional way.
Unfortunately, we
won't have time
to cover that today,
so sorry about that.
Because once we went
through figuring out
what it takes to run your
code in a multi-regional way,
we realized it's really
complicated, maybe much more
complicated than it should be.
So we have just enough
time to cover that.
But the good news is that we
talked to the social engineers
guys at Google who is really
interested in this topic.
And they're going to come
up with some solution
papers in the next few
months on running your code
multi-regionally and storing
your data multi-regionally so
that people can get an idea
on what to do on both fronts.
Because it doesn't make sense
to have your code running
multi-regionally when your
data is in a single region.
So with that, first let's
talk about why we should even
care about multi-regionality.
So James, you want to
tell us more about that?
JAMES WARD: Yup.
So, we, and many others,
have data centers
all around the world.
And so we have this compute
spread all over the place.
And so why would
we actually want
to have all these data
centers all around the world?
So I want to give an example
of New York to Tokyo.
Does anybody know how many miles
it is from New York to Tokyo?
Guesses?
6,737 miles.
And I think that's
a straight line.
So, that's a lot
of miles, right?
But we all think like, hey, our
data is traveling via light.
And light is really fast.
But it actually turns
out light isn't really
fast at that kind of scale.
Does anybody know
how long it takes
light to travel from New
York to Tokyo and back?
Guesses?
It's actually 72 milliseconds.
So just to get light from
New York to Tokyo and back
takes 72 milliseconds.
And that may not
seem like a lot.
That's only 72 milliseconds.
But in a typical
web application,
and the way that
TCP works, we're
actually making these back
and forth things all the time,
over, and over, and over,
just to load one web page.
And so, this adds up and
stacks on top of each other
to create a lot of really
high latency for our users.
So if our data center is in New
York, and our user is in Tokyo,
then this latency can
really add up and create
a bad experience for them.
So, by moving the actual
service of what we're serving,
the app that we're serving, as
close as we can to the user,
we can really significantly
reduce the latency
that our users experience.
So that's one big
reason for why we
may want to be multi-regional
in our application
is just to reduce latency in our
application and for our users.
And then there's
also definitely comes
into play is we're communicating
across microservices.
So if we have microservices,
and one is in New York,
and one is in Tokyo,
then those microservices
are going to have high latency
communicating with each other
as well, so not necessarily
just about the user experience.
It could be service integration
experience to you and latency
around that.
So then another reason
to be multi-regional
is just to be able to protect
ourselves against outages.
A lot of times when
outages happen,
they should be pretty isolated.
But sometimes, they
can propagate up.
And these can be
because an engineer
like me makes a
mistake, or it could
be because of some major
catastrophic act of God.
And so by being able
to be multi-regional,
we can now avoid some of
those issues around outages.
So let's talk about
how we actually
would build a multi-regional
architecture to handle
these scenarios
to reduce latency
and to deal with outages.
So we're going to start at
what we call the zone level.
So the zone level--
you can think of a zone
essentially as an
isolated data center that
is protected from other outages
or other issues in other zones.
So it has this isolation, so
it is essentially a data center
with its own network, its own
power, its own backup power,
all those things together.
And so we're going to
start with the zones.
Our apps always will
run in a specific zone.
And so we need-- that's
essentially getting down
to the server level.
We've got to run on a
server at some point.
And that server is going to
be in a data center, which
you can think of as a zone.
Then we have this idea
of aggregating together
different zones into a region.
And so if you want
your application
to be able to be
resilient across a region,
it needs to exist
in multiple zones
because potentially a
whole zone could go out.
If there's something crazy that
happens in the data center,
or somebody makes a mistake
in a network configuration,
or something like that,
can take out a whole zone.
So if you want to be resilient
at the regional level,
you need to be spread
across multiple zones.
And so we have many
different regions
that you can choose from.
And there's US West.
There's a couple in US West.
There's Tokyo.
There's Europe, all sorts
of different regions
that you can choose from.
But region is just an
aggregation of multiple zones
for your application to run in.
So, we've got these
multiple regions.
And that's great, but we don't
want to tell users in Tokyo,
hey, you need to
go to FooTokyo.com,
and users in Europe
to say, oh you
got to go to
FooEurope.com, right?
That's not going to work.
We want to send them to Foo.com.
And so then we have
to have some way
to be able to give them
a single endpoint that
then will route traffic to their
nearest region that they're in.
And this is what a
global load balancer
does is it provides us a
single IP address, and thus
a single domain name, that
we can give to our users
or to our services.
And it then looks at the request
and where it's coming from,
and we'll route it to
the closest location
and make sure that
what its routing it to
is up and able to
handle requests.
So then our users are happy
because our users in Tokyo
automatically go to the
Tokyo region service.
So great, that's how our
global load balancer works.
But let's actually take a
look at what this actually
looks like.
So I'm going to start here.
I've got-- this is going to get
a little tricky because we're
running two different windows.
Our Chrome browser on the left
is running, actually running.
The browser itself
is actually running
on a virtual machine in Europe.
And then our Chrome
browser on the right
is a virtual machine
running in Oregon.
So left, Europe, right Oregon.
Maybe we should've done that
the other way, geographically,
but that's OK.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to load an application here.
And you'll see the address
for this application.
That's 35.244.
We're going to load that
same address in the other one
as well.
But what this app
is doing is when
it loads, it figures out where
the application is actually
running, so not where
the user is coming from,
but where the application
is actually running.
So this application
is running in Belgium.
So it's in the Belgian region.
And then it tells us how--
the ping time that it took,
how long it took for the client,
which is also in Belgium,
in this case, to make
the request to the region
in Belgium and get a response.
So it was pretty
quick, 49 milliseconds.
And then it shows us a nice
picture of Belgium, of Saint
Ghislain, Belgium there.
OK, so that's great.
But what we're
going to do now is
go to that same exact
address, but we're
going to do it from Oregon.
And now the apps says,
hey, I'm running in Oregon.
And we get pretty good latency
there, 121 milliseconds.
And we see a weird
picture of a building
from the dowels in Oregon.
So that's great, same address.
See, that's the key
with this whole thing
is we went to the same address.
And that address
routed us to the region
that was closest to where
our request was coming from.
So now we're able to get
much lower latencies.
If I were in my Oregon virtual
machine to go directly-- so
I'm not going to go
through the load balancer.
I'm going to go directly
to my Europe region,
and we try to load that, you'll
see that now my latency is
much higher.
So I'm now accessing--
I just bypass the load balancer.
And now, my latency is much
higher, up to 361 milliseconds.
So not terrible, but if we have
to stack a bunch of requests
on top of each other, this
is going to get really
slow really quick.
So let's go back through
the load balancer here.
And see, things are
much faster when
we access the region
that's closest to us.
There's one other
thing here that we
can do is we can go
in and let's simulate
a catastrophic
disaster in Oregon.
So I'm just going
to actually do that
by turning off all my
instances in Oregon.
So we'll turn all those off.
And it'll take a second
for them to shut down.
But now, if we go
back, and now we
try to access from
Oregon this application--
and we'll have to wait a second
for them to actually shut down.
But what's going to happen
is it's going to now say,
I can't access the stuff
that's closest to you,
so I'm instead going to route
you to a server error or her.
METE ATAMEL: That's
shouldn't happen.
JAMES WARD: There
we go, to Belgium.
So it's now routing us to
Belgium instead of that service
that was down.
So now we get that fault
tolerance across those regions
just built in.
And of course, things
are going to be
much slower while that
Oregon system is down,
but at least it hasn't
crashed and is just
not working for users.
So there we go.
That's how we now have our
global load balancer that
is able to route stuff to the
closest application to the user
and handle outages across us.
And let's go back
and scale that back
up so that future
demos work just fine.
METE ATAMEL: Thank you.
JAMES WARD: All right.
METE ATAMEL: Cool,
so that was good
for the high-level
description of what
an app should look like that's
tolerant and multi-regional.
But how do you do
this on Google Cloud?
Before we talk
about that, we need
to talk about how we can
run code on Google Cloud
because it's a little
bit complicated.
There's a lot of options.
So let's go through those
options first, one by one,
look at the options that you
have when you run your code,
and then take a
quick look of how
to turn that code running
in a single region
and make it multi-regional.
Now, let's take a look at this
from low level to high level.
At the lowest level in Google
Cloud, there's compute engines.
These are basically
the virtual machines
running Windows or Linux
instances in a single region.
You will basically
choose the CPU
you want, the memory you
want, the storage you want,
and the VM is ready
in 30 seconds.
And then once you have it, you
can install whatever you want.
It's yours.
It's not maintained, so you
have to take care of software
updates and everything.
But it's yours to keep.
And it's mostly for
applications that you already
have running in a VM.
You want to move
them to Google Cloud,
you would mostly
use Compute Engine.
Then if you make the switch
to containers, from VM
to containers--
you probably heard
about Kubernetes, which
is an open-source project
to manage containers.
And you also probably
heard about Istio,
which is also an
open-source project
to manage the traffic
to your containers.
In Google Cloud, with a
single G Cloud command,
you can get a Kubernetes
cluster with Istio enabled.
So with just a
single command, you
have a cluster running
with Kubernetes and Istio.
And that's where you would run
your continuous applications
with full flexibility.
So whatever you want to
do with your containers,
scale them, connect
them, Kubernetes
gives you all of
that flexibility.
And Kubernetes
Engine is the place
to run that on Google Cloud.
Now with flexibility
comes a lot of complexity
because Kubernetes has its
own vocabulary, like pods,
and deployments, and services,
that you have to learn.
So there can be a
little complexity there.
We introduced something called
Cloud Run a couple days ago,
which is a really easy
way of running containers
in a serverless way.
So in Cloud Run, you basically
point to your container,
and then you just say,
deploy this container
and scale it for me.
And what Google Cloud
does is that it basically
deploys the container, routes
to traffic to the container,
takes care of
scaling down to zero
when no one uses it,
scales it up to whatever
you set automatically.
So all those details of running
the container and scaling up
and down is taken
care for you, and you
don't have to deal with
the low-level details
like Kubernetes and Istio.
Everything is abstracted
away from you.
But maybe you don't even
want to care about containers
because containers, even though
they're nice abstractions,
you still need to worry
about writing a Docker file.
And you need to worry
about your dependencies
and make sure that your Docker
file is actually optimized
so it doesn't take too
long to load your content
and things like that.
So you maybe as an
application developer,
you want to deal with
source code and not
the infrastructure.
And for that,
there's App Engine.
App Engine has been
around for a long time.
And it's kind of serverless
before serverless was popular.
In App Engine, you write
your code, deploy it,
and you still get
serverless features,
like scaling down to zero
and scaling up easily.
But you also get traffic
splitting, versioning,
and other features like
dashboards and things
like that for free.
And finally, maybe you don't
even care about applications.
You just want to write some
piece of code in a function,
define the input and
output, and define
what triggers that function
and let Google manage the rest.
So for that, there's
Cloud Functions.
So that's for source-based,
event-driven applications.
So this is the
stack that you have
when it comes to running
code on Google Cloud.
And it's up to you
basically where
you want to be in the stack,
the low level at Compute Engine
or at the highest level
at Cloud Functions.
But the key thing is that
all of these options,
they are basically--
they're always running
in a zone in a region.
So they're not really
designed to be multi-regional
by default. They're not
even designed to be regional
by default. They're designed
to run in a single spot--
a single zone in a region.
So you have to do work yourself
to make it multi-regional.
And at the high level,
this is how it looks like.
So for Compute Engine, there's
Google's Global HTTP, HTTPS
load balancer.
So there's really
good support for that.
So you would
basically set that up.
So you would deploy two VMs
in two different regions,
and you would set up the load
balancer in front of them.
And there's good
support for that.
Now, if you're on Kubernetes
Engine and Istio land,
things are a little
bit more complicated.
So there's-- so if you're
running Kubernetes on Google
Cloud, or on-prem,
or some other place,
there's Kubernetes Federation,
and there's two versions
of that that we'll talk about.
There is a tool
called kubemci that
helps you to set up an
HTTPS load balancer in front
of your Kubernetes clusters
that we'll talk about as well.
But it's a temporary solution.
There is something called
multi-cluster ingress with GKE
that we announced last NEXT,
but it's not ready yet,
so we cannot use it today.
And finally, if you are
using Istio for your traffic
management, there is a way
to configure Istio so that it
spans multiple clusters.
And that's also an option.
So this story is complicated.
And hopefully we'll
get to the bottom of it
at the end of this presentation.
And then for Cloud Run, and App
Engine, and Cloud Functions,
unfortunately Google
Cloud doesn't support
any native solution today.
So what that means
is that you need
to deploy them yourself
in multiple regions,
and you need to figure out
a load balancer in front
of them yourself, something
like Apigee, or Cloudflare,
or NGINX, or
something like that.
But we'll talk about
all of these in detail
as we go through
the presentation.
Now first let's talk
about Compute Engine.
Now, if you want to deploy
code to Compute Engine, one
wrong way of doing that
is that you get a VM,
you install whatever
you want on the VM,
and you repeat the process.
This works for maybe five VMs.
But if you have to
manage thousands of VMs,
it doesn't work.
It doesn't scale.
And it's error prone.
What you need to do
is, first of all,
you need to create what's
called an instance template.
And from the instance
template, you
need to create an instance
group to manage those VMs.
But to get to the
instance template,
you need to do a
little bit of work.
So let's go through that list,
see how to create an instance
template first.
First you start
with a base image
Google Cloud has a
lot of base images
that you can rely on
for Windows and Linux.
Or you can also
input your own image
if you want into your
project and use that as well.
By either way, you
start with an image,
and you get a VM running.
From the VM, you can
install other things
that you need on that VM.
And once it's ready, you can
take a snapshot of that VM.
So the snapshot basically
takes a snapshot of the disk
that the VM is attached to.
And then you can use that
disk to create other VMs.
But the snapshot
is project-scoped,
meaning you can only use
it within the same project.
You usually have
multiple projects,
and you want to be able
to share this snapshot
with multiple projects.
So for that, you create
something called custom image.
So custom image is
basically a snapshot so
that you can share globally
with multiple projects.
But you don't usually
take the custom image
and then run it as it is
because different regions
and different apps need
different configuration.
So what you usually do is
that you take a custom image,
and you use startup
scripts, and use it
you use metadata service to
get configuration and setup
into your custom
images so that they
are customized for the
region that you are running.
And from then, you can
create an instance template.
So that's the journey
to instance template.
So instance template
basically combines
a custom image, and
the startup scripts,
and the metadata
together into a template
that you can use to create
groups or instances.
And finally, you can use Cloud
API to create these instance
groups.
So the Cloud API, you can use it
from G Cloud command line tool.
So when you use G Cloud command
line tool, it uses the API,
or you can use the
client libraries
in any language you want, or you
can use the REST API directly
if you want.
But either way, you're
going through the Cloud API
to create these groups.
So from the instance
template, you
create something
called instance groups.
These are basically groups of
VMs that are managed for you.
They are based on a template,
on an instance template.
And these instance
groups, basically
once you create
an instance group,
it manages the VMs for you.
So if a VM goes down,
or it's not healthy,
it will bring it down and
create a new one for you.
You can also set auto-scaling
on these instances.
So you can set, for
example, the min
and the max size
of these instances,
as you've seen in James' demo.
You can easily scale down to
zero manually or scale up,
or you can also
set auto-scaling.
But the key thing is that
although this is still
single zone or multiple
zones, but they're
still within the same region,
so it's not multi-regional yet.
And as I mentioned, you can
hook up and auto-scale it
to your instance group.
And you can set
policies on that.
So you can say, for example, I
want to scale from zero to 20,
and I want to be--
I want to do this with CPU.
So the autoscaler will
look at the average CPU,
and it will scale up and down.
It will basically
instruct interest group
to scale up and down depending
on the policy that you have.
But this is still single region.
So you might be wondering, why
are you showing me all this
because it's single region?
And James will
tell us about that.
JAMES WARD: Yeah.
So when we create our instance
groups in our instance
templates, that's
in a single region,
so we need to be able to take
that to multiple regions,
and then put the load
balancer in front of that.
So the solution is to put
the load balancer in front
of our multiple regions.
So we need to set up the
instance templates, which
can span multiple regions.
But then we need to
run our instance group.
So we'll run an instance group
in East or West in Europe.
So we'll run our instance
groups every region that we
want to provide service in.
And then we put the global
load balancer, the Google load
balancer in front of that.
So the way that we
do that is we first
need our global IP address.
So we go and reserve a global IP
address for our load balancer.
So our load balancer will
have a single reserved
IP address that we use
across the whole world.
And then we set up
a forwarding rule.
So the request is going to come
into the load balancer, which
is a machine running in
a data center somewhere.
And then it needs to know
what to do with that request.
And so we tell it, hey,
here's what you do,
you need to actually call
this thing over here.
And so that goes
through a proxy.
So we set up a proxy,
which is going to allow
us to do some URL maps.
And ultimately,
the proxy is going
to point to our backend
service, which is
running in a specific region.
So we're going to tell our load
balancer about all the regions
that our application
is up and running in,
and define those all as backend
services underneath the load
balancer.
And then those actually
can forward the request
to our app that's
actually running
within a region and
then within a zone.
So those are actual backends.
So the path that this goes
through on the internet
is that the end user is
going to make a request,
ultimately to an IP address.
That IP address is going to
resolve to the region that
is closest to them.
I think we use like multi-homing
or something like that
to magic tricks with multi-homed
IP addresses to make that work.
But that IP address routes them
to the closest region where
there's a machine,
the load balancer,
running that's going
to handle that request,
look up the information
for where to forward,
where it can forward that
requests to, and then
try to get that request
forwarded to the region that
is closest to the user.
And then we can set
up-- we have to set up
firewall rules, which
allow the load balancer
to talk to our instance group.
So we need to make
that request possible.
We in our set up just expose
through the firewall rules
access to the world to
our backend services.
And you probably
wouldn't want to do that.
You'd probably want to restrict
it so that only the load
balancer can actually
make requests
to your actual backend
instance groups.
So you set up your
firewall rules,
and then you set
up a health check.
So the health check is a URL
that the load balancer is going
to be periodically calling.
And then that's what
tells the load balancer
that that region is good
and can handle requests.
So that's how we set
up the load balancer.
But let's see what it
actually looks like here.
So in the Google Cloud
Platform console,
first we're going to
go check out our--
let's go to our
instance templates.
So you'll see that we have a
couple of different ones here.
But the one that we showed
you already was this one.
And so this was where
we went and created
the template of how
to create instance
groups in the multiple regions.
So, there's a few things that
we have specified in here.
There is the firewall
configuration
that is specified through
this network tag, HTTP tag.
There's the container image
that we're pulling down
from the container
repository image information,
so what size CPU do you
use, and that sort of thing.
So that's our instance template.
And then from there, we
created our instance groups.
So there's the instance
group in Europe
that we're using and the
instance group in Oregon
that we were using.
And so if we go into one
of these instance groups,
we can see this is
really just created--
instances created
from a template
and potentially auto-scaled.
So you'll see it's
pointing to that instance.
Auto-scaling is off in our case.
And then we have the actual
instances, the two instances,
that are up and running
the application there.
So those are actual
underlying instances for this.
So that's the structure,
instance template,
which allows us
to create instance
groups in multiple
regions, and then
the actual running instances
that are running within zones.
So now let's take a look at the
load balancer configuration.
So that's under Network
Services, Load Balancing.
And the load balancer that we've
set up that you've just seen
is called Web Map.
And here you'll see
our public IP address.
So that was the one,
if you remember,
that I loaded at first
in those browser windows.
So that's our public
load balancer IP
address, the single
IP address that we
use to access everything
behind the load balancer.
And then you'll see
that I am giving it
the instance groups, the Europe
and Oregon instance groups.
And then it knows how to then
route the traffic as you saw.
And then we can go check
out our health check here
to see what that's doing.
That's going to our
URL/ping and some parameters
around that health check.
So that's how we put
together the load balancer
along with the instance
templates and instance groups
to make this not just
a regional application,
but now a multi-regional
application.
METE ATAMEL: Great.
And the key thing is that
there's all native support
here from Google, so we didn't
have to use anything external.
And you get the geo
load balancing for free.
The global load
balancer figures out
where the user is and routes the
request to the nearest instance
group.
So that's the key thing.
Now for Kubernetes
Engine and Istio,
things are a little
bit more complicated,
so let's go through that.
So the landscape is that--
so if you are
running Kubernetes,
there used to be a feature
called Kubernetes Federation
version 1.
There was a group that worked on
that for a year or so, I think,
and then it was abandoned
because it didn't--
it didn't handle use cases,
and it wasn't stable,
and all that kind of stuff.
And now there's a V2 coming up.
There's another group
that's working on that.
And the last time I checked,
it's still evolving.
I haven't seen-- I think it's
either alpha or beta stage.
But I haven't seen it being
used in production yet.
But if you are using Kubernetes
inside or outside Google Cloud,
you should keep an eye
on Kubernetes Federation.
V2 will get to the final
stage, and maybe it will be--
you will be able to use it.
But as of today, I didn't
feel like it was something
that you can use in production.
Now in GKE, in Google
Kubernetes Engine,
the clusters are actually
deployed in a single zone
in a single region.
There is something called
regional GKE clusters,
meaning you can have
a GKE cluster spanning
multiple zones.
But those are still
in a single region.
But one thing that
you can do is that you
can create two clusters in
two separate regions yourself.
And you can load balance
between them if you want.
This works, but it's manual.
And you need to-- basically,
it's two independent clusters
that you need to manage, and
you need to load balance--
set up some kind of
load balancer yourself.
Now, there's a tool called
Multi-Cluster Ingress
and there's the
command line tool
called kubemci
that's open source,
and it's supported by Google.
And if you look at Google GKE's
documentation page and kubemci,
right at the top, there's
a red font message that
says "This is only temporary.
Don't use it."
But I'm going to
show it here today
because of unfortunate reasons
that I'm going explain.
But basically, that's
a tool that you
can use to set up two
clusters in two regions
and load balance them using
Google's HTTPS load balancer.
Kind of like Compute Engine,
but it automates that for you
so you don't have to do
all those steps yourself.
kubemci does it for you.
So you might wonder, OK, if
kubemci is temporary, then
what am I going to use?
And ultimately, you'll be using
something called Multi-Cluster
Ingress Controller, or MCI.
They were announced
last NEXT in July.
But last time I checked,
it's still in progress.
And I asked PM can we have a
version that we can play with?
And I couldn't get one yet.
So it's in progress.
But eventually that
will replace kubemci.
And maybe next
year, I'll show you
a demo of that, but not today.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to talk about kubemci today.
But keep in mind that
it's going to-- it's
a temporary solution
until the other MCI,
which is implemented using
ingress control rule,
comes along.
Now, kubemci, it's
a command line tool
that you can use to load balance
within two separate clusters
deployed in multiple regions.
But there are some restrictions.
Each service must be configured
exactly the same way,
meaning that you need
to have the same name,
they need to be in the
same namespace names,
and they need to
expose the same ports.
And they need to be the service
type NodePort in Kubernetes.
So this might be a
limiting for you,
but you have to basically do
this in order to use this tool.
And the way to do it, I'll just
show you some G Cloud command
line tools quickly so you have
an idea how to set this up.
First, you need to
create your clusters.
So in Google Cloud, you just
use G Cloud container cluster
Create, give it a name,
defined the number of nodes,
define the zone.
So this creates a
cluster in Europe,
then you do the same for US.
So you have two clusters
running, one in Europe,
one in the US.
Then to get your
code into Kubernetes,
you create a deployment.
So you create a deployment yaml
file with the your container
image and stuff like that.
And you have your code running.
Then you need to expose your
pod to the outside world.
So for that, we're
going to use a NodePort
service because that's what
kubemci forces us to do.
So we do that as well.
And then you need to let
kubemci manage your cluster.
And to do that,
you basically get
the credentials of your cluster
and save to a KubeConfig file.
So I'm getting the
credentials of my Europe West
and the credentials
on my US West.
Save to a file.
And then finally, I need a
static IP for my ingress.
So I reserve that static
IP on Google Cloud.
And then I point--
I create an ingress
resource for my kubemci.
So I basically
create a yaml file
that defines my
ingress that I'm going
to show in the next slide.
And I point to my project,
and I point to my KubeConfig--
the configuration
for my MCI config.
So once you do that, the kubemci
can list the ingress IP for you
if you want.
You can see the status.
And then you get an IP,
and you can curl that IP,
and get your cluster.
So these are the steps.
And just to show you--
I am not going to show you
the deployment or the service
because these are Kubernetes
things that you probably
know about already if you
are running Kubernetes.
But the yaml file
for the ingress kind
of looks like this.
You basically say, this
is my service name,
this is the port that I want
to expose my external load
balancer basically, and then
you add a couple of annotations.
So you're saying this
is my static IP name.
So this is the IP
name that I had
when I created my static
IP in Google Cloud,
and also did an ingress
class that tells me
this is a multi-cluster setup.
So once you have this, you
can expose these two clusters
in two separate regions
using ingress with kubemci.
And yeah, let me show you this.
It's not going to be
too different than what
we had before.
But if I come back here, instead
of going to Google Compute
Engine instance, I'm
going to GKE instance.
And one thing that
you'll realize
is that this is on HTTP
not HTTPS because I
was too lazy to set it up.
Sorry.
If I come here, then it's
the same kind of thing.
From Europe, I go to Europe.
From US, I go to US.
And if you look at the
configuration, first
of all, the Kubernetes
Engine, I have two clusters.
One is where-am-I-Europe-West
and the other one is where
am-I-US-West.
So these are my
Kubernetes clusters.
And if you look
at the services, I
have the ingress services and
the NodePort services that
are also exposed that I need.
And if you look at
the look balancers--
So this was the look
balancer for Compute Engine,
but I also have a looked
balancer for the kubemci.
And that's pointing to the
ingresses, the backend services
basically in Kubernetes.
So that's how it is.
And so that's Kubernetes
without Istio.
But if you are running many
microservices on Kubernetes,
and if you want to manage the
traffic to your microservices,
then it makes
sense to use Istio.
And normally Istio runs
in a single region.
For example, there's this
book info application
that you probably
have seen on Istio.
It's a sample application that
has multiple microservices.
And usually these are
deployed in a single region.
But there is a way to set
Istio in a multi-cluster way
where it can span
multiple clusters.
And these clusters can
be in multiple regions.
So in this case, for example, we
have one of the microservices.
We used V2 running
in the US West,
and then other one
running in US East.
So you can do this kind of
setup in multi-cluster Istio.
I tried this.
It works.
And if you go to Istio
documentation page,
there's a couple of
different flavors
that you can use to set this up.
But we won't go
through it here today
because it's a little bit
complicated and too many steps.
But it's something
that actually works,
and then you can use as well.
OK, so that wraps up the
Kubernetes/Istio part.
And lets talk about Cloud
Run, and App Engine,
and Cloud Functions land.
JAMES WARD: Yep,
moving up the stack.
So if you want a higher
abstraction level,
instead of doing
GCE or Kubernetes,
you want to move up to
Cloud Run or App Engine.
Let's talk about how that works.
So for our serverless
compute, there's
different abstraction layers,
Cloud Functions, App Engine,
and Cloud Run.
And the way that you set up
these to be multi-regional
varies a little bit.
So I want to run through that.
So if you're on App
Engine, when you
create an app in
Google Cloud, it's
tied to a specific project.
And you can only have one
app, one App Engine app,
in a given project.
And each app has
a single region.
So in App Engine,
there's this correlation
of one project
has one app, which
is tied to a single region.
So if you want to
be multi-regional
with App Engine, what
that means is you
need to set up multiple projects
and one project for each region
that you want to be in.
So that's what we have
to do for App Engine
to be multi-regional.
For Cloud Functions, we
can have multiple functions
in a given project.
So that's good.
But each actual
function in our project
is tied to a specific region.
So if we want to have a
multi-original function,
then we need to have multiple
instances of that function,
multiple functions essentially,
in different regions.
And then for a Cloud Run,
that will also be true.
But today, Cloud Run
I think only works
in the central region.
So today, only one
region for Cloud Run.
So we can't quite be
multi-regional yet.
I'm sure that's coming.
But when we do have
multiple regions,
it's very similar
to Cloud Function.
So each time we
create a deployment
in Cloud Run,
essentially our app, then
that runs in a
specific region, so we
need to have multiple ones.
But at least we can have
multiple Cloud Run apps
or project--
deployments within
a given project.
Now for all of these
options today, you
have to use an
external load balancer.
So Apigee is a great
option because that's
something that is part
of the Google family,
just not fully integrated
into the Google
Console and that kind of
thing yet, but great option.
Or you could use another
load balancer as well.
So those are your options around
the serverless side of things
for how you go multi-regional.
METE ATAMEL: One
thing to add here,
but we are working on a more
Google Cloud-native solution,
load balancing solution,
for all of these.
It's not there yet,
but it's something
that we are working on.
But for now, we have to rely on
something external like Apigee,
or Cloudflare, or
something like that.
And Apigee-- I don't think
I will do justice to Apigee
because it's such a
complicated product,
but I only use a
small part of that.
But what is Apigee
is that it used
to be separate
company that Google
bought two or three years ago.
It's an API proxy, an
API management tool.
So you can basically set a proxy
that points to either servers
or points to any endpoint
that's running anywhere,
not just on Google Cloud.
And then you can set
very complicated rules
on those endpoints.
So you can do
pre-flows, which means
when someone hits that
endpoint, you can run some code.
Then you can
post-flows, which means
that when someone
comes out of the code,
you can do some
complicated things.
You can load balance
between anything
really, like any endpoint,
you can load balance.
You can set pretty much any
kind of rule you want on that.
They have a really
good developer console
where you can visualize
things and see
how the traffic is flowing.
You can even debug your
endpoints from the console
that I'm going to show.
And there's many other
things like machine learning,
intrusion, detection,
and all sorts of stuff
that I haven't played with.
But just know that if you need
any kind of API management,
Apigee's a really great tool.
Now what I use it for is
that if we have App Engine
applications, and we had
the App Engine endpoints,
all I want it to
do is that I want
to have a single endpoint
where I can load--
I can do geo load balancing.
So if a user is in,
US-West, I want them
to go to US-West App Engine.
And if they're in Europe, I
want them to go to Europe.
So I just set that
up with Apigee.
And it was really easy
and really intuitive.
So let me just show
you some of that.
So this is the App
Engine console.
So it's a separate console.
It's not part of Google Cloud.
So you have to work with that.
And you can set many proxies
that you want, API proxies.
But here, I have a proxy
for my multi-regional app.
And then what you can see is
that there's prod and test,
so you don't have to push
everything to prod by default.
You can test them out
in a test environment.
And once you are ready,
you can push them to prod.
And then under here, you can
see the endpoints that we are
exposing, so multiregion-atamel
is my base endpoint,
but then /gae is my
App Engine endpoint,
/CloudRun is my Cloud Run
endpoint, and stuff like that.
So these are what's
called proxy endpoints.
I have a default one.
And I also have specific
ones for specific products,
like the App Engine, or Cloud
Run, or Cloud Functions.
And then these proxy endpoints,
they point to target endpoints.
And these target
endpoints, basically
they are things that you define.
They can be some
endpoints in Google Cloud,
or they can be endpoints
anywhere, really.
The default one-- and by the
way, this is the UI part,
but you can also switch
to developer mode.
And in developer mode,
you can see things
in a way that makes more
sense, at least to me, in XML.
So, for example,
the default one,
I'm saying that it's
a secure endpoint,
meaning I'm going to use HTTPS.
And my target endpoint
is default as well.
If you look at the
target endpoint,
I have tow servers defined.
And I'm just run
[INAUDIBLE] between them.
So these servers I
define what their IP is,
and what their port is, and
it will [INAUDIBLE] in them.
If you look at the
App Engine one,
here I'm saying my
base endpoint is /gae.
And it's also a secure endpoint.
And then my target endpoint
is GAE Europe West and GAE
US West 2.
And I also have a condition.
And in this
condition, I'm saying
that if the system has a region
name that starts with Europe,
then send it to Europe West.
And if the system region
name starts with US,
send it to US West.
So that's how I'm doing a geo
load balancing with Apigee.
And if you look at these target
endpoints, GAE Europe West,
it's basically just my
App Engine and a URL.
So this is a
multi-region in Europe.
And this is multi-region
2, which is in the US.
So that's how you set it up.
And once you have that, you can
also do tracing kind of things.
But maybe I won't--
yeah, I won't show that
here because it's not
showing up here.
But basically you can also
trace these from the console
and see where the
customer's going,
and which conditions are being
met, and stuff like that.
But for some reason, it's not
showing up here right now.
JAMES WARD: It's the scale.
METE ATAMEL: Yeah,
it's the scaling,
or this is a little bit weird.
Yeah, so that's how
you set things up.
And I guess you can show
us how it works in Apigee.
JAMES WARD: Yeah, so
the App Engine side.
So over in Google
Cloud Console, I'll
show you the App
Engine parts of this.
So if we go to App
Engine, remember,
I can only have one App Engine
app within a single project.
And so our project is this
multi-regional atamel.
And this is my App Engine app.
And so we can go in and
look at the services.
I've got a service there
with multiple versions.
It took us a little bit of
testing to get everything up
and running.
And then underneath
the App Engine,
we're using App Engine Flex,
so there's actual instances
underneath that as well.
So these run ultimately
on GCE instances
underneath the covers.
So that's one app.
If we can go just to
actually load this thing,
and you can see it.
So this is not going
through the load balancer,
just going direct to this
particular application.
So all the way to Belgium took--
our round trip was
567 milliseconds,
so pretty long there to
get to Belgium and back.
So now to be multi-regional,
we needed another project.
So we can go select--
whoops!
METE ATAMEL: Oh!
JAMES WARD: Uh-oh, do not
search the dictionary.
There we go.
We'll this again.
So we've got another project
here, multiregion2-atamel.
And so now we're in the
App Engine one for that.
And we've configured this App
Engine app to run in US West.
And so if we go
load that, then we
get our Los Angeles one there.
So, very similar,
same container image
that this is based on, so same
application underneath the
covers.
OK, so that's our App Engine.
And then, of course, we can
go test out the load balancer
part of this as well.
So if we go to our
endpoint for our Apigee,
then we're at-- remember,
left is Belgium,
so it routed us
correctly to Belgium.
And then if we load that
same endpoint in from Oregon,
then you'll see that--
I don't know why we
picked Los Angeles.
But anyways, it's now
going from Oregon,
where the VM on the right is
running, down to Los Angeles
and back, so a little
bit higher latency.
It should be a little
bit faster in that,
but let me try it again.
There we go.
That's a little better.
So it did route us
to the closest one.
It didn't route us to
Belgium, so that's good.
So there we go.
That's Apigee now running in
front of the App Engine apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]